je vous ai tous invités à ce prime et
vous avez une invitation un petit peu
particulière sachez le
puisque pour ce prime refait l'année on
voulait marquer le coup et on voulait
les invitations symbolise s'effacer dans
l'année regardez la première partie de
cette remise d'invitation avec les
invitations de mathieu kelly et
jean-michel regarde alors un mot o'kelly
pour résumer cette saison c'est pas très
original mais c'est vrai d'arc à cette
saison ça a été je prends ça mais la
meilleure pas pour moi mais pour toute
l'équipe tron s'est jamais autant marrer
un mot pour résumer cette saison je
dirais de leur mort mais parce que c'est
celui qui a été une fois de plus meyer
qui a le plus donné de bonheur aux gens
c'est délicat quand même remporté le
trophée du meilleur chroniqueur et ça
c'est à dire combien se monterait
chocolat
[Musique]
l'invitation sera basse et le chocolat
mon pire souvenir la première fois qu'on
s'est pris du chocolat dans la série je
t'emmerde
voilà mais cette fois ci bien profond te
dit je t'aime quand même bien la vallée
par nelson benjamin castaldi
valérie bénaïm et maxime j'ai dit et on
a isolé ensuite doc gynéco cela me fait
seul vous allez voir doc gynéco c'est
incroyable c'est le seul mec qui prend
du chocolat mais il continue d'une
interview comme son last en regard des
benjamins valérie et maxime on va
revenir un peu sur la saison on revient
sur l'avenir sonia les pires souvenirs
ok d'ailleurs toi oui on entend
quelqu'un lemay qui pensent qu y avoir
des craintes de la perche alors pour toi
en un mot comment tu peux résumer cette
saison veille un mot formidable délire
regard bosser pour se marrer pendant
trois heures c'est formidable pour
mesdames je suis tellement pas sur un
terreau est accrue j'ai beau père où il
tombe bien souvient son frigo c'est
lorsque du public est venu chanter pour
cyril je crois que c'est un fou rire que
j'ai eu un excellent il avait même
quitté les plateaux de lingerie confiait
souvenir nantais ppc quoi est ce qu'on a
vraiment des pires souvenirs
peut-être la première fois qu'on a pris
du chocolat dans la fille
[Musique]
tâchons français
on l'a fait on a fait pas mal bavé en
fin de saison
c'est peut-être un peu difficile à lui
voir sur le moment mais en gardant les
images comme très très drôle
[Musique]
ce salopiot de regret ou pas non à zéro
regret à part peut-être le chocolat
[Musique]
son habitation sa sortie doux windows
ton cul je ne savais bande de connards
tu vas te la [ __ ] dans ton cul tu en
as mis du temps mais c'est encore une
idée d'al oula ça j'en peux plus de vous
je peux plus te voir cyril je ne peux
plus te voir
bon ben j'ai pas envie de vous dire
merci
plus vous voir et vous êtes là dedans
mais c'est vous qui comprenait plus à
chaque fois c'est fait mais je sais pas
si c'est moi pourquoi il ya un truc
vraiment je suis toujours dans le dans
laxe et y en a qui n'a toujours pas
compris qu'il avait pris du chocolat ce
n est qu à chaque fois il reste
tranquille une élection continue the
show must go
regardez pour lui il ne plus aborder ce
n'est pas le chocolat
si cette interview qui a ensuité résume
en un mot son arrivée sur tnt
on a seulement bien je suis arrivé hier
[Musique]
avec l'adjectif qualificatif c'est à
dire et comme bien nouveau comme un
nouveau que s'écrit sur touche beaucoup
de différentes données beaucoup de
choses que je note un peu ce qui se
passe que je peux plus ou moins
comprendre de la situation pour pouvoir
m'adapter
j'arrive à faire un peu le numéro 10
cachet à ce poste de numéro 10 caché
qu'un ami imaginaire ou pas oui c'est
qui
[Musique]
et une tendance au plateau mais alors là
cette année la nouveauté de cyril
s'amuser c'est beaucoup beaucoup amusé
avec vous cette année avec quelque chose
qui est tout surpris parce que t'as
kiffé chocolat ou pas
[Musique]
la refaire
ban
[Applaudissements]
regardez je veux le revoir on veut le
revoir
allez-y alors on est en train de le
recaler au magnétoscope un beau coup
vous produisez avec vous cette année
avec quelques chutes de tout surtout
elle se fait chaud là bas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]